- 出發的東西
- 那今天再進入我們那個說書的系列
- 我們發現Tony哥其實他有一個獨家的專長
- 他很會剖析交易贏家的思維
- 興趣
- 跟他的路徑還有成功模式
- 那我們前面已經繞過日本啊
- 再次回來台灣了
- 那台灣的話Tony哥這次要跟我們分享什麼
- 你講到我真的是我的職業病啊
- 每次看到那種書我就很想要去分析
- 說他到底為什麼成功了
并可以学习到很多东西嘛
那我们也谈过
交易冠军马丁·索瓦茨
讲过日本的那个主力的思维
那我想说这次我们把触角拉回到我们台湾
有没有一些比较优秀的这种操盘人出的书
我也蛮有兴趣去分析一下
然后我疑问之下呢
大家都比较推荐就是两本书啦
是最近出版的
就是一本的巨人的思维
那下一集我们要谈的就是飞是思考
这个都是我们现在所谓的少年鼓声
不知道可不可以这样说
都很年轻
所以我想我们把触角拉回到我们本土
感觉这两本书我看完以后
我觉得真的是蛮不错的
那我也觉得现在真的
所谓的英雄粗糙年
像我们都算老一辈的
不会
但是呢
我们看到年轻人
有这样的一个成就
那有这样的一个程度
然后也愿意出这样的书
来跟大家分享
我觉得真的是蛮给鼓励的
然后我看完这本书也觉得
内容很精彩蛮高的哦
出乎我意料之外就是
他们算是蛮愿意分享
你家的故事
它里面提到很多
蛮技术层面的
OK
对不是完全是断记
所以我觉得这个是
真的会对台湾股市比较有兴趣的朋友会有帮助
所以我们赶快来开始
我们第一本书就来谈的就是这个巨人的思维
那我就直接到他那个书面的编辑
我就来把重点跟大家分享一下
好第一个他就讲说年轻的时候
其实他应该现在也算年轻啦
就是说他更早期就是刚进到这个市场的时候呢
他就提到就是说他其实的一个对于教育的看法
就是像打电动一样
电玩这个我觉得真的是我非常认同
因为你记不记得我那时候说
我那时候在做海龟的时候
也是站在一个好像
现在年轻人都会打电动嘛
那反正像你看这个
他也提到他很喜欢用闪电下单啊
所以我也扣了一个闪电下单的界面
如果各位朋友到现在
没有看过闪电下单的话
这就是一个标准闪电下单的格式
当然每一家都有每一家的格式啦
像你们群艺
然后有群艺的格式嘛
不外乎就是在那边点来点去嘛
对
这边买这边卖这边买这边卖
其实说穿的就是真的跟打电动一样
对
所以等我当年我去培育海龟
我的想法也是说
年轻人打电动只要打得好
那来做交易
做一些短线的交易呢
因为他的这个走啊眼啊的反应是很快
所以我相信一定有关联
所以我们看CIS他也有提到
这个他们都算同的世代
所谓的电玩世代
是
所以大家对这种荧幕上的那种操作啊
其实都非常的驾心就熟
所以CIS也好
或我们讲这个巨人节
还有当年我在培育海贵的时候
我也是用CS啊
枪战的那个
当场让他们打
那个时候最有恐怕
很久以前
所以我覺得
如果你不要去講到那麼高深的學問的話
其實以短線
或者說我們講當沖在那邊
純粹拼交易技巧來講
或者說我們講反應程度來講
真的我必須說交易可能跟電動八成相似
這是一個邏輯
因為我自己有電玩電動
對只是我的反應沒有像他們那麼快
但是我知道那個是相通的
對
所以應該說是電玩世代的紅利
那他有提到他早期也是靠短線交易
然后他也觉得说
这个用闪电下单去下单啊
跟这个打电动是一样的
所以我在这边也跟大家呼吁
就是说现在的年轻人啊
如果你觉得真的没事干每天在那边打电动
不要觉得自己一无四处
不定你就是很会用闪电下单的高手
所以我觉得说这个
透过巨人思维这本书
他也印证了这个讲法
就是说现在我们这个年轻世代
电动世代啊
真的或许你是一个短线的
本来就已经马上就可以无缝接轨的
這樣的一個高手
這是我覺得第一點要跟年輕人鼓勵一下
大家不妨來試試看
或許你真的比打電動
既好玩呢
又可以賺到錢
我以前在培育很貴的時候
常講他們很多都是電話很高手啊
就是新的東西出來
馬上破關
我說那你得到什麼
得到就是再買下一片
花更多的錢
破關了
對
可是如果你用這個破關了
你得到了就是
一直衝高財富了
對
你破關的獎品就是可能是一台跑車
可能就是一棟好彩
這樣有感非常有感
對呀同樣是破壞嘛
對
對一個是花更多的錢
一個是什麼都有啦
得到人身上的成就
對呀
所以我覺得天生我才必有用
對愛打叮咚的小孩
未必沒有出入啦
是
這個給年輕人看到
可以去試試哦
真的不是開玩笑的
好再來他說啊
他因為對教育很有熱忱嘛
他說呢教育模式
早上呢是做台股日經
下午就轉到歐洲盤
做這個德國
歐洲籃籌
富士
這些都是挑出來
都是流動性比較好的啦
對
那晚间当然一定是玩美股嘛
再来玩清源永和黄金
都做最火波的时候
对
而且是早上下午晚间
就是24小时全年无休
我觉得这也是我觉得很好玩
是很多年轻人真的都有做到这个
不只他一个
像我一个徒弟也是一样
眼睛总是红红的
然后每次早上都在睡觉
后来我也跟他讲说
你这样的体力真的可以负荷吗
对
他说没办法
行情大了之后
当然时段都会动嘛
所以呢
都有钱赚会受不了
我猜他可能也是会稍微看一下行情
你看前阵子行情这么大
对
当然是不能放弃啊
你早上中午下午
如果有体力都要玩啊
所以这一点我也觉得是可以跟大家分享
就是说确实很多年轻朋友们是有做到这样的
就全天候全球交易
这个是蛮有趣的一个
我觉得可以鼓励啊
趁年轻
当你有体力的时候真的可以这样干
变成是一台24小时一朝节
随时都给我钱赚
那我觉得博安也可以去分享一下
你看他第一个就是什么
很喜欢看美国重要数据的公布
CPI啊
PC啊
这个越来越重要
你不觉得现在台股
尤其夜盘完全就是跟着这个在走
对
尤其特别让我感受到
就是说今年
这个重要性
甚至已经取代了传统的那些技术分析啊
对
你完全是照着美国的数据在走
有时候转折就在这时候出现
对
所以夜盘现在变成说
我觉得跟日盘不相上下
它的重要性
甚至很多好的那种
价位你都要在夜盘去考
OK
然後這又跟真的跟美國的重要數據的公布有很大的關係
而且它層面越來越廣
對
以前可能我那時候看你們都在推廣什麼非農啊
像你不覺得已經越來越到什麼
三年財報都要出現了
對現在
因為盤後財報最近全市場都在看輝達
所以我覺得這個是一個很重大的轉變
這個也是跟大家提醒一下
因為這本書已經出版一陣子了
那我覺得它是已經很早期就開始發掘到這個現象
然後再來它的第二個策略就是說
他们会想要去赚取周选或月选的时间价值
Sale
所以他有部分是正在选择卖方去赚这个时间价值
第三个策略就是说他会用个股期
有点去试单
他试错策略的意思就是说
我看到一只股票好
但是我先用个股期去试单
那他有讲这个句话我蛮认同的就是说
如果我试单的情况下我发现你是没有动作
因为个股期的交易这个成本很低嘛
他有讲嘛
以成本或手机会来讲的话
比起真正去玩股票算是零成本
幾乎啦
對對
所以他用這個去試
像我感覺那樣子去發動的話
我頂多就抽出來
因為我的成本低嘛
不會說我進去以後
我就一定要付那麼高的手續費的情況下
所以他用各務期去試
那我再猜啦
既然是試的話當然
如果他照我的想像中發動的話
他的大軍應該在
現貨裡面去
在那邊去攻擊
我猜的啦
所以我覺得這些呢
都是我發現呢
比較可以跟大家分享的策略
重心
对 那我们再继续看
那在交易技巧方面呢
他有提到几点
就是他要靠试单去找方向
OK
所以他很明显会分主力
他会分试单
那试单是用多少呢
就比例大概是10%
比方说他可能想要下10口
或10张股票
那他就先下1张1口
先去试试看对不对
他连那个都讲得很详细
他的一个单数
他是用几秒钟去感觉
对还是错
这个针对当冲啊
对应该是
几秒钟啊
应该说
但我来看也不见得完全当充嘛
OK
如果他会这样写的话
就代表他可能这个策略是蛮痴
这种动能
蛮痴这种顺势突破的
这种顺势突破的东西啊
你几秒钟其实真的就会知道对还是错
这个又很敏锐了
特别的属性
比方说你如果很喜欢玩那种逢低布局
对
你想想看你逢低布局然后你去买
你几秒钟之内真的不会有感觉
对那个要等
搞不好你一进去以后可能还要等
几个小时他就落底了
对
然后才会再上来
可是这种你如果要突破都不一样
突破的东西呢他是骗不了人的
你如果突破然后在那边爬
打完会下来
那所以他这个比较针对突破啦
突破的交易才会用几秒的感觉
如果比第二点来讲
我认为他是针对那种强势突破
甚至那有可能是这种创天价
或者说我们创今年的最高价
或这一季的最高价
或100天的最高价
这种的策略呢
就满适合用那第二点这种试单的感觉
这满合力的
对
如果是做突破的话
所以呢
他用几秒钟
这个是我觉得特别有趣的地方
他把他讲出来就是说
几秒钟
去感觉我的下单
下去的对还是错
那一看就马上加码
其实我觉得这个东西是真的有很尽量
像我来讲的话
我也可以讲
比方说我下台子骑的当中
像这种一定也是做下那个
突破day high或day low
是
就是当天的最高或最低点
那我的参数也可以跟各位讲
我大概最多5分钟
OK
你突破我用5分钟没有喷出去
我一定砍掉
OK
那他的話他更敏銳
他是幾秒鐘
要立刻發動
而且他厲害的地方是說
他覺得只要感覺對的
他馬上去加滿倉喔
他的強調是滿倉
對是滿倉喔
所以我覺得這個是殺氣很重的一種做法
但是我覺得年輕人就是這樣子嘛
蠻不錯的
第一個他的一個盤敢好
再來就是說他很傻很敢抽
所以這個都是一些成功的特質啦
是
再來第三點
部位放大以後呢
順勢策略會增加
逆勢會降低
為什麼齁
我觉得这个应该也是跟
交易的原理有关啦
你不会放大以后代表你对了嘛
对了以后呢
当然你的顺势策略
有点趁胜追击的概念
因为我们讲就是说
对要冲嘛
错要守嘛
那逆势其实某种程度上讲就是说
你本来就逆这个大字
所以逆势的话呢
其实比较不适合大
不过也是真的
所以我觉得这个就是他一些
你可能去看这个书
如果你没有实战
你不见得会
体悟到他讲
对你可能会觉得说他讲
可是跟你没什么关系
比方说像讲这个几%
很多人他说我只能下两口
那两口哪有什么10%
对
所以他这个东西并不是说每个人看以后都会觉得对我会有感觉
第一个你一定是已经做到中上的这样的一个资本
对
好啊接下来我们谈到
我从这本书里面我剖析他的教育策略
那在一般人来讲也没有什么叫满仓
对
平常下一口最多满仓两口
看这一点都没有感觉啊
那还有什么部位放大
甚至有些人觉得我根本就没有什么叫
顺势策略也没有什么历史策略
所以我觉得这个可能是针对
你做交易已经到一定的程度可能三年后五年后比较容易去感受到啦有一定心得或是说办专职对对对对才会有体会到这样的交易技巧好这一点我都好觉得就是我们常在提
有没有
我们是不是在很多里面
有提到双率
对
所以这边我用双率来解释
就是说他说
他把所有的时间都用在
如何去研究
去拉高我的赔率
而不是去研究
怎么提升我的胜率
风暴比
对
风暴比就是赔率嘛
对对
不晓得
一般人聽風貌比會比較懂
還是聽賠率會比較懂
反正講同一件事情
那麼雙慮就是勝率跟賠率嘛
那我們過去好像拍過影片就是說
勝率這麼重要
散戶認為勝率很重要
那常常人家問人家說你勝率多少
這波有看對嗎
這是散戶的思維
對
但是其實他從這裡就知道說
這個是一個專業的玩家的思維
就是我們不太談勝率
都是談賠率
對
所以他也把他的一個研究的重點
放在如何去拉高我的賠率
而不是說我去研究怎麼提升勝率
這個就是專業玩家跟賞戶不一樣的地方
對賞戶其實告訴他這個
可是他們常反饋給我們就說
可是我勝率不高的話
我小賠小賠也會變大賠
對賠率再高
他們好像就很難意識到這個東西
其實我覺得最大的原因是他們沒有大賺
對大賺的時候都是差什麼
他們沒有能力大賺
所以他會覺得說我提高不了賠率
我也不知道該怎麼提高
二千萬也沒成功過
對
那我提升不了培育師
我只能提升勝率
所以我覺得這個有點是好像不得已的
所以我覺得對產物來講
你應該要先幫助他們
去嘗過真正賺到過大錢是什麼感覺
要賺第一次
對一定要賺過第一次
去體會那個感覺
而且他相信
他能賺過大錢以後
才會有機會
去跟他談所謂的什麼風暴比
他才會體悟到這個真諦
重要性
不然的話產物都是這樣子啊
以期貨來講
可能賺了50點100點
就觉得很多啦
这个他永远不会体会啊
他赔都是赔100点 200点
对更多
所以他分率量很高啊
因为他赔一次200点
赔一次100点
所以我才说看书是这样
你看这本书就大概知道他的level
知道他的定位
还有他在市场上给自己的
交易风格大概是长什么样子
那我们来看第二点
就是说他单点进出
如果没有去加解码的话
无法提高赔率
这一点我不晓得博焱的看法怎么样
他进一步告诉我们
你为什么一直赔率都没办法拉高
因为你都用单点进出
所以单点进出就是说全部都买在这个价格
对然后再出在那个价格
你在A点进B点出
然后接下来又是A点进B点出
OK
你可能在A点不管你买几口啦
假设你买5口
那就在B点出完
你可能又下一个点你又买3口
他又在B点又出掉
这个满冷头
像我们也是跟特务这样讲
就是从点变成区
我说这个上下
那上下可能就是有一个固定的逻辑
可能上下加8个Tick
4个Tick
依照商品
依照当时的波动
对
那你的成功气率就比较高
我们买在相对低
卖在相对高就好
买最低卖最高
就真的大家没有这样的能力
对
以我们这边的用語
我们称为叫点对点作战
就是说
你永远只会下单点
讲是说用区啦
对
他的讲码是这样
他是认为说
单点还要加上加减嘛
OK
才能完成
一个比较完整的交易
比方说他刚刚提到试单嘛
所以你再加上前一页讲的试单
你就知道
他的加解碼邏輯就出來了
比方說我先下一兩口
但是對的我直接就壓十口進去了
這就是所謂的加碼
那我在猜一定是說
等到你的動能消失以後
你再慢慢的去減碼
他先收一些
然後其他的就讓他跑
所以他這樣的話
他的賠率當然就可以提高
因為他是瞬間
所以他賠的話是一兩口再賠
對
可是他賺的話呢
就可能就是十幾倍在賺
因為他加解碼速度很快
所以我在猜他可能他的賠率
有可能到1賠7賠8
有可能
如果說這樣講的話
應該就是錯的話
可能就是那10%的小病部位
對
那看對話就直接放下去
我在猜他一放下去以後一定也是
那他跑不動的時候已經就收很多了啦
因為他是滿倉嘛
對
你滿倉你在hold住的話
你的風險是沒有必要的
因為盤停下來休息了嘛
你停下來休息是只有兩種可能
一種是橫盤嘛
一種就拉回了嘛
對
所以他一定是出到可能一半以上
其他的我就跟你拚你整理完
然後去再抽嘛
這是我個人理解
他如果巨人集有看到這部影片的話
你也可以跟我们分享
看看我讲的对不对
因为我如果是以你这样的做法
我年轻的时候也是这样做
那我会这样的比例去调
但是你这个1比9
我可能没有到这样
我可能就是比方说
那时候我一下选择权比较多
我可能一下就是30个50个我选择权
如果对的话
我可能就直接100或200个我就下去
所以那比例大概是在4到5倍啦
对那1比9就比较稍比较多
那但是呢我会看冲出去的程度
你冲出去如果到很远我就不太管
你已经远离我的成本了嘛
对那你冲出去的地方
如果离我成本还很近
我就会收5成回来
ok 如果你有冲那么远的话
对
那你如果再冲不出去
我就整个收了
我大概是这样的手法
我在台阁里应该类似
所以我大概你这样讲
我就可以理解你整套的
手法大概是什么样子
就跟大家分享
不过应该没有关系
因为就写在书上了
应该我讲出来也没有关系
就是看大家体会的程度
然后再来他提到
就是说成交量大的个股的话
他会去选这个来
作为他交易的标的
那他把财数讲出来
就是他会选这种
第一个一定成交量的比较容易进出嘛
要大
成交量打工性
这来他有提到就是说
最大的日政府他抓大概5%左右
很大
其实他后面讲原因
因为你5%的日政府就表示你跌下跌到5%嘛
可是事实上你能吃到的确实没有错
也就差不多一半左右
对
他讲2到3%其实就是2.5%
2.5%是不是刚好是政府的一半
所以你看我们做台子企也是一样
台子企如果像现在
台头大概都是200多点
我们基本上能有效掌握大概就100多
因为你要扣头尾
合力报酬啦
对你头尾不可能通通拆到嘛
所以
头尾一定是让掉
所以你中间那一块肉大概就是政府的一半
所以我觉得他这样讲是合理的
虽然说你说政府5%蛮大
可是你每天去选一定有
他可以去选比方说这个月
或上个月或上周
日政府比较大的
然后直接让你大的来做个股
这个可适用性范围就很大了
比方说你可以做当抽
你可以做波段都可以
所以我觉得这个也是蛮重要的一个技巧
就是不是说你喜欢这支股票
我就买来当充
你该满足一些条件的
第一个你流动性好吗
第二个就是波动性好
这个我已经讲了很多次
包括我们在很多时候
我们在讲对于海企商品的选择也是这样
对
你一定要去选那个流动性比较好
然后波动比较大的去做
那他把这种方式应用在课股上也是一样的
好
再来谈交易理念的部分
交易理念他说啊
第一点波动就是短线人吃饭工具
都完全正确
所以大家一定要放在心里面的就是
喜欢做短线的人呢
唯一能够让你吃到大鱼的就是波动
所以我常讲波动率大的就是大鱼
波动率小的就是小鱼
对
反正你都只能吃中间嘛
小鱼的中间一定是没有肉啊
大鱼的中间随便吃到一块都很大
像现在这种行情就是每天都是大鱼
对
所以像这种行情基本上你做趋势还不见得
能够做得很漂亮
对
你做这个短进短出啊
在這個時候反而啊
工錢小
然後呢賠率高
對一天大漲一天大跌
對啊那你短線無所謂嘛
反正我固定就吃200點300點我就跑掉了
像最近不是盤在這邊橫盤
對啊橫盤範圍很大
對
大概在6-700點了
你只要固定吃中間200-300點
其實你只要放一兩天一定會賺
而且多空都能賺
所以這個大家就體會啦
短線人看的是什麼
活動
然後他再來就提到這個就是
所有上林股神的共同戰利品
就是2020年那一波啊
资金行情
那一波是
我们最近在路也有讲嘛
2020年那一波真的是送分体啊
再也很少看到说短期内那样子
一波到底这样子
这边Tony哥可以分享一下
为什么他们
大家都认为是送分体
是从什么样的面向看到的
其实那时候我好像也听到很多
都在谈什么
甚至有一个叫什么
直接去谈什么疯狗流
最近不是出事
他其实就是把它讲的更白话一点啊
什么叫疯狗流
意思就是说
反正你
只要一直追就對了啦
但是我有聽過一些年輕人的做法是
反正我今天賺的就再捲進去
再賺的馬上就再捲進去就是
拿衛兵商去加碼
對 甚至看也不一定要是衛兵商啊
那可能今天也有可能是當中啊
今天我賺了 今天當中賺到錢
明天我就直接在
又更大的部位又再衝進去
他們等於說處在於一個很短的
一直循環加碼
因為像那一年就是三月份崩下來嘛
那時候三月份我記得台股也37%
每股代跌4期
其實最強的意思是5月那一波
對
因為4月一個B嘛
那他們會認定說是送分
一定就是在
就大概是9月落在什麼時候
5月份
5月份一定是5月
1月到8月那一波
就看到4月份的這個B之後
對
ok
因為那個之後
可以說抽馬起的很乾淨
再加上有題材嘛
對
所以你很少看到就是說
每一支股票都是連漲的
ok
他是不休息的
你沒有遇到這種行情的話
這種方式也不可行
你很少看到一支股票可能
比方連續20天當作市長
對
那他們就是遇到那一波
當然是送分體
因為這種波動剛好
就是你可以真的是把每天的獲利
就再加碼下去
因為我這樣問是
我覺得這可以幫這些粉絲朋友
再找一下未來的送分體
假設出現一個大普的籌碼洗乾淨之後
就出現一個B
然後
不過也要有一點題材啦
對要有一個大題材
那都剛好就是遇到比方巫二戰爭
然後又遇到那個
傻錢
5,000QE
QE當然也是
那另外一個很重要的因素就是
因為那時候主要就是塞港
那個貨輪都全部很少遇到這種狀況
那跟疫情也有關係
那疫情後
大家又拼命的消費嘛
對
所以變成說貨物量又變大
因為大家出不了門嘛
所以我覺得那個真的是天時地一人和
不是說單就一個技術面
是
或是一個資金層面要配上事件
所以當然是疫情加烏合戰爭
烏合戰爭構成蓬蓬
然後再來疫情
然後大量的網路消費
為什麼說這種真的很難遇到就是
天使啊
對那真的是可遇不可求
對
那剛好遇到年輕人又比較不怕
像我們
通常有這種行情我也不敢這樣做
所以你說那個
如果我們知道那種行情再來的話
當然就是
他們這種做法
甚至我知道很多都是做品種
直接品種可以做到10倍
10倍10倍的這樣一直壓下去
我們現在的話
對我們這種情貨人來講
我們當然是用Buy Call
對
Buy Call一直轉倡一直轉倡一直轉倡
然後不然就是用這種
退伍期嘛
所以我覺得這個都是
你去看
尤其下一本书
我们讲那个飞食四老
他都有吃到这一波
对
所以他这些年薪股神
其实都有吃到这一波
吃到就电力好基础了
对就等于说你的资产会大膨胀
只是说有没有守得住
对
我觉得这些比较成功的
都是算有守住
但我知道的是很多都是隔年全部吐掉
对
应该你有听到过
很多上的股神都是
那一波赚以后隔年就吐光了
这在我们自己客户中有些
曾经成为赢家的演示
守不住
因為他把這個當成常態
你看他已經可能資產搬了100倍 200倍
對啊後面的壓法還是一樣因為他會讓我們再來而且那個勸不動對沒有辦法人都會被過去的成功給束縛住那我們也是啊像我們來講我們根本不覺得會有這種行情
所以我們也不敢是這樣的玩法
那就是變成經驗把我束縛住了
當然他們可能會賺到那麼多獲利
也是因為當初這個衝啦
對
可是後來就是也是因為這樣子的賠掉
所以啊
這個就是你的交易風格固定以後
你就只能賺這種錢
你賺了這種錢
你不改
就會在這種地方賠掉
我們是賺不到這種錢
但是也不會在這種行情輸掉
所以這有時候很難是遇到就是說
你在這個地方可以賺到
你又知道怎麼去改變你的打法
對
這種就是真的
萬中全益的天才
就像巴菲特也是這樣子
巴菲特你常笑他說
你在科技股都賺不到
所以他也說
我就不懂
所以我就不賺
可是同樣科技股補版的時候
他也沒傷到
對
所以這有時候就是一種
打他看得懂的好球
我們常講就是說你賺你該賺的錢
你不可能什麼錢都賺的到
這種的話我只能說好厲害
我賺不出真的賺不到這種錢
那個通靈哥也是巨人堂的啦
沒有沒有我是靠經驗
但是我的經驗裡面
這個不在我的經驗範圍內
不在我的經驗範圍內我就看不懂
看不懂東西我就不敢做大
對合理啊
對
但是同樣的真的你說別下來我也沒想到
這個就是每個人都有自己的命啊
真的不要去羨慕人家說
那個誰賺很多那個賺很多
但是我們可以去理解
去試圖去分析說他們為什麼可以賺到
從這裡面我們可以學習到就是說
那我們賺不賺到這種錢
那我們如果想出這種錢的話
我們必須要做什麼改變
我覺得還是看這個書的意義
可能他講出來有100個優點
我們如果可以吸收個三成四成
是啊
內化成自己的東西就很棒
那一方面我們也很好奇
就是說這些所謂的新一代的
我們不想說少年古神
新一代的這種成功的案例
到底他們都是
我也很好奇
因为说实在这些年轻人
他们的成功好像都是在我
复活期间
忽然间回来以后就发现
因为台湾怎么好像氛围不一样
年轻人都现在好厉害
那所以我也是很好奇
想要去了解他们做对了什么事
好我们来看第三点
他说不必逆事对干
顺势交易都能够赚钱
这是他的一个交易理念
对他来讲就是说
顺势交易还是他的一个主軸
其实我也觉得说
这种顺势或逆事啊
真的有时候很主观
对要怎么去定义
你說做得多就是一定買紅棒嗎
也是這樣子
因為這個對我來講
最狹義的逆勢是什麼
是在跌的時候去買
就是你還在跌喔
然後你就進去擋它
對
幾漲或一段很長你去空它
就是
比如說假設今天漲300點400點
一路去空它
這我就是逆勢嘛
那如果說你是漲一段以後
比如說我們漲1000點
對
虧個300點
再去接
這到底是不是還逆勢
OK
這個就
一人而異啦
你要说他是逆市你可以说
明明在跌的时候
跌市中你又听街做多
不过看他的前面的交易行为
他应该也是属于就是
因为他做突破了嘛
对
所以应该就是刚刚讲的
应该如果说多的话就是买红
一定都是买红居多的
对应该是他主要的策略是这样
我刚刚提到的就是说其实啊
如果我们把时间拆割再细一点的话
其实我认为每一种交易
他的基本原则都是顺势
只是说他是5分钟的市
还是1分钟的市
还是30分钟
还是日线
周期
对
比如说你跌了
比如说今天可能盘中一个
击杀个300点
但是他一分钟冲起来了
那我去追
那我到底是孙氏还是逆氏
我是顺着短线那一分钟的氏啊
也是孙氏啊
那你结束就是要一分钟出现变化
什么时候要依照一分钟的周期走
对啊
所以在我来看
所有的交易都是孙氏
只是说你的时间
怎么切割而已
继续用一下看
他说带怎么厉害的分析啊
在连续的暴涨暴跌之下都没有意义啊
这个最近最能够体会了嘛
这句话也蛮厉害
我们最近不是在录了一篇
就是说这个股灾的歧视
我不是跟你讲
我们谈到就是说
在这种股灾下面啊
你什么样的技术分析
基本分析都没有用
就是在讲这件事情
在怎么样的基本分析
重码分析
什么分析
真的在市场非理性的时候
这些分析都没有意义
反正呢该跌它就要清到完
涨的时候就要嘎空嘎到爆
因为这个时候只有输赢了
就是所有的东西都是要做清啦
在这种清洗浮耳的情况下
或者说我们讲去杠杆的情况下呢
你什么分析都没有用
因为那个势头太大
这个能够体会这一点的话我觉得也蛮重要的
因为很多人在这个时候呢
为了说服自己
还去讲一些说
啊这个地方已经超跌了
为什么还在跌
这个地方明明本一笔已经不合理了
因为这个地方没有意义可以啊
去拿基本分析
价值分析
但是都没有意义可以
你说这个地方已经破底了
这里都有支撑
这从技术面来看嘛
那正正在暴涨暴跌的时候
哪有什么支撑压力啊
所以这个时候千万不要撒到说
尤其8月这种行情有没有
去接到这种你不管用什么角度
你就千万不要去跟我讲理性
不管怎么样你都不要去跟我谈说什么
基本面怎么样
这是股票好跟坏
对
所以当下来讲是没有意义
又全面有意义
他说这里明明均线在哪里
哪一条线在哪里
哪个字撑在来都不要讲这个
一点意义都没有
价格才是真的
对
反正他只有止跌才是真的
要看到
对要看到才是真的
就是这一点在讲的事情
再来他说
你只要用同一种策略来交易
你不要想贪太多的策略
这个换句话我会这样讲就是
我常常跟我的那些徒弟们讲就是说
李小龙不是讲吗
他不怕练一万种招式的
对
但是他怕把一个招式练一万遍的
所以你只要同一种策略
这个策略能够让你赚到钱
你就一直用这个策略
它可以让你在不同的时间频率
在不同的市场都能够赚到钱
但是你用太多策略的话呢
有时候你可能根本就下不了手
而且很有可能就是到处都自圆其说嘛
对
你就說這個時候這個策略可以有用
比方說你本來打順勢的
然後呢你被阿發你就說
你看這個地方有支撐壓力
我覺得也是不錯
我們就用一種策略就好
再來齁
所有市場呢都有效
這時候有上工就有錢啦
休息是浪費
意思就是說
你如果這個策略
目前是有效的話呢
你用在他剛剛不是
有早市、午市跟晚市
都會有用
這個策略都會有用
所以呢他說這個時候
我為什麼要休息
我不要休息啊
因為我設個策略
比如說這個其實很簡單嘛
在暴漲暴跌的裡面
你就是進去賺那個動能的價差嘛
對
吃一段吃一段吃一段
那你在台股也可以吃
你在歐股也可以吃
在美股也可以吃嘛
他說遇到這種機會的時候呢
你就是要努力一點
就是打滿全場
因為這個時候就是發紅利的時候嘛
對
不要說這個時候怕累
要去休息
賺錢的時候
對你就是用這種
就是吃動能的這種策略
ok
好這個他又講了一遍了
他說呢
他看重賠率呢
勝於勝率
真的贏家都在講這個
對全部贏家講的東西都一樣
對
嚴格控制分母
職母他的概念
對應該就是說
那個分母就是什麼
風暴敵嘛
對
對所以那個分母就是風險
風暴
對分母嘛
對不對
下面一定是風險上面是報酬率
好聽懂
Return除以Risk
ok
然後操作大部位的話
應該事先規劃退場
我覺得應該
很早有這種困擾
一般人都沒有大部位了
他意思是說當你有一天成長到
你可以操作大部位的時候
因為大部位要出場的話會有流動性的問題
你覺得這個真的做大這句話很重要
對 但是這句話就是你沒有玩過大部位的
沒有什麼共鳴
他已經是部位已經大到的程度了嘛
所以變成說退場會有流動性的問題的情況下
他才會說應該要事先規劃退場策略
所以他指的是流動性
而不是說可能一些
航情的變化之類的
這個一定有
但是他操作大部位的話呢
一定是要更着重于说
它的市场的为纳量
尤其我在猜这个一定是有可能它在操作一些
流动性相对比较差的
比方说有些个股它可能一下子
真的在跌的时候完全没有买单的啊
有些个股是这样子啊
那甚至可能有些期货商品是会这样的
这种状况你就要先去想好
那你说的可能是一般的状况
那是一定要做的
那是本来的功课嘛
你不管你大部位小部位
本来就是应该先想我怎么退场
那這邊有提到超多大部位
ok 那更要小心
所以我來說一般人可能沒有看到這一點
因為他沒有玩過大部位
對我來說我比較少這種困擾
因為我一定是選那種最有流動性的
我才敢去下比較大的部位
ok 再來我們看這一點
他說穩定獲利比大賺一票難很多
所以重點不是在預測
因為你要大賺一票一定是跟預測有關
對
你就猜反正這個地方就是低點
這個地方就是高點
然後我就all in
這種做法很容易大賺一票
可是這種做法的另外的反面的缺點就是
你很容易一直賠
對一個職業操盤人來講的話
他會說他重視的一定是穩定獲利
既然你要追求穩定獲利的話
你的重點他就不會放在預測
這個我們在交易情商裡面有提到
不是有一篇我們講說
預測是毀滅的開始
前陣子才路過
大家有興趣可以去看那一篇
我也是講你穩定獲利來講
你盡量一定要降低你的預測的成分
ok
那你不預測
怎麼樣才穩定獲利
就是你剛剛講的
順著市場當下的走勢
去賺錢
雖然可能不會賺到
原來打
可是你要打出一雷安打二雷安打
會非常的高
ok
那你每天都有機會嘛
累積一樣會變大錢
是
所以呢
對於這些產品來講的話
我們他寧願靠穩定獲利來
凝聚成一筆大錢
而不是說我一次就要賺到那個大錢
那個是賞戶的想法
ok
所以我在那邊提出來的教育理念就是
我覺得說我認同
有產生共鳴的就是
對於一個職業玩家也好
或是一個比較成功的玩家
他的思維到底跟一般
或者說失敗的
或是散戶的思維
他的差別在哪邊
另外剛有提到一般的朋友的通病就是
不太願意從小撥開始練習
哇真的
我真的覺得一進來就玩一筆大的
你有沒有這種感受
長到一點甜頭之後
對啊
你有在接觸是看路都是這樣嗎
都all in
對啊他長到一點甜頭就all in
想不動
就飛起來了
對那個風險維持率都是100%
然後覺得說
這麼好照顧
然後也可以不怕
就是不管現在的機會大或小
當下的勢頭是怎麼樣
就是擺到滿
做棋位也這樣做選擇權也這樣
這個都是要從頭訓練起
對那個就是真的要
黑到一定的空檔之後
可能才會蘇醒過來
這個不管是在法蘭還是
我們以前在訓練的時候
全部都是從一定是模擬開始
是啊
你模擬可以的話才開始從小部位開始
這個我們都有很嚴謹的這種規劃
這裡面我就聯想到
真的每個人到最後都有個極限
比如說一開始大家可能小部位來講
可能一口兩口三口對不對
有些人到最後就可以下到100-200口
有些人就是到10口20口
就會停住了
所以很好玩
你從這裡就看得出來就是每個人的個性
他會決定他最多可以下多少部位
但是一定大家都是一種小部位開始
應該說贏家啦
贏家真的是這樣子
贏家真的到最後每個人會達到的那個level
還是有差距的
是
好像是贏家
有些人就是億的
有些人就千萬的
有些人就百萬幾
是
ok好再來他說他通只交易台股前30大標的所以你就知道他很在意流動性然後到了最後他只交易前三大這個是指成交量
我在猜他可能到最後他覺得說
反正我用的方法都差不多嘛
那我用前30大我不是很累嗎
那有些流動性大有些流動性小
我還要去照顧那麼多
我不如集中火力再只攻前三大
其實這樣子想也沒有錯
就像我們有很長一段時間都是指下台子期
也是這樣過來
那時候金融商品沒那麼多
所以只有台子騎可以玩而已
頂多再加上個OB
台選這樣而已
還不是照樣玩的福一樂福
所以我覺得這樣的想法也是可以理解
因為他的錢真的膨脹太快
所以變成說他在玩前30大的時候
很多東西他覺得沒有必要去賺這種錢
他書中有提到他可能從多少的財富
撞到多少財富
這個我好像沒有印象
照我看書的直覺來講
可能一開始都是幾十萬
然後到達到幾百萬
可能我在猜現在他們都應該都商議了
對
對啊都是跟原來比都是上百倍的
所以他一定是不再玩這些
就算前30大來講對他來說
我們必要花時間去搞這個
集中火力去玩前三大就好了
交易重點就好了
對
這個剛剛講過了
重複出現
部位放大也要順時策略增加
你時策略降低
這一點我覺得很有趣
我特別把他提出來
他說
很多人都在比股票年資
你做幾年
這樣子喔
開戶的時候也很喜歡你
交易資歷啊
對啊你常常看到那些老伯
我在看盤的時候有沒有
常常跟你講那個說
民國幾年的時候怎樣
民國幾年怎麼樣
那這邊一針見血啊
因為我覺得特別有趣把他講出來
他說應該是說
你這輩子做過多少的量來拼資歷
而不是說你玩過多少年
這個也有道理
用交易人的角度來講
就以我們其他人來講
就是說這輩子做過幾口
我以前真的被嗆過
我年輕的時候在寶萊當醫救員
有一次一個給經營的月曼去演講
去的時候死了
全部都是從十步
都是那種一億以上之產的
他一樣叫我上去講什麼
紀錄分析
講不到十分鐘被轟下來
這是我很少被轟下來
那時候又小心你就有點受傷
他跟你講不要跟我講那個
我先問你你今天做幾口
就牙口不眼
那時候你二十幾歲
你要叫我什麼
你先一天做到多少口
你要跟我講話
跟我鼻子趕快下膽
就紅下來
那經理人就安慰我說
這種大戶都是這樣
要習慣
大戶都很難適合
所以我就下面決心被嗆了
後來我就進資源了
這會有一個啟發
後來就有人在嗆我啦
我說你今天做幾口
我說做4萬
真的啊
我那天做4萬口
我就說我今天做4萬口
而且我那時候做我OP做很大
我一個月做OP做到200萬口
到300%
我暂市占率大概5%
是
所以我說你今天如果做2P的話
100口沒有5口是跟我對做
總共成交量也才這樣而已
對 就5%
這個我說我很認同啦
就是說教育人的想法都是說
你不要跟我講年資啦
一年下10口下10年也才100口
對 所以你跟我拚資利
你就跟我拚交易這樣
這很有趣啦
跟大家分享一下
我跟他這個有講過了
操作大波音 事先規劃退場
這個都重複
後面呢應該有一大段在講說
我們在交易的成長過程當中
會遇到一些重大的階段
那可能你自己會去體會一下說
你可能現在在哪一個階段
第一階段一定是beginning luck
就所謂的新手運
會覺得就像你剛剛講的
你下子很順的就回應了
對
那我就新手運嘛
結果下場一定是大賠
然後你就發現說不是靠運氣嘛
對
然後再來就是說想去學一些分析好
學了很多技術分析
然後發現技術分析也不是萬能的
不是學了一兩種就馬上飛上天了
我覺得很多交易的人都卡在第四點了
對
就是學嘛
學了以後又期待很高嘛
結果呢
你才知道說原來交易這條路沒有速成的
ok
然後後來你也發現說
老師去預測呢
結果都讓你失望嘛
所以到最後你也會放棄預測
那我認為從這邊開始就慢慢轉向
是不是滿正面的
這些都是不斷的進化
你知道這裡我認為就是
慢慢擺脫loser
你從開始放棄預測我覺得就慢慢轉向
有機會賺到錢
然後再來加強情緒控制
是不是就走向正面
那你能夠拉高賺賠比
我認為你已經進入到贏家階段
然後最後你會把一個興趣變成你的工作
對於交易的興趣
或對投資的興趣
然後後來會變成直接操板就變工作了
所以我覺得他這是一個一般人會經歷過的
進化石
的進化石
我後來看我也是從這邊開始
我從
會不會有開始玩嗎
不過好像沒有經歷過新手
一開始就大賠
一段股賽
這樣比較好
然後呢
之前都是看報紙嘛
後來就去學技術分析嘛
學完以後發現也沒有用
後來呢
我這個是我真的到完全進入到職場
我進到智營部以後
我才發現預測是錯誤的
不然以前我也很喜歡預測
我那時候學波浪嘛
所以很喜歡預測
我反而沒有經歷過這一段
因為那時候我已經在法人
法人沒有什麼情緒公職的問題
因為你只要
情緒失控馬上被趕走了
一開始就把平常性訓練得很強
對因為我在這裡的時候就進到法人
那這些對我來說就變成說
這些都是自然形成的
這頁的含金量非常高
這頁我覺得是真的是把他
可能自己的心路歷程也有參考進去
那麼接下來呢談到就是說
怎麼去做交易檢討
那我們就快速帶過了
他說檢討自己的交易紀錄是一個最有效的訓練
但是我覺得這個真的是要下苦工啦
因為這比較苦工
對而且就是一般人收盤就覺得收盤了嘛
對
那我要放鬆我要休息
我很累我要運動
很少人就愿意再花
而且这个
一般一个正确
而有效的交易记录
通常要一到两个小时
就是有时候到三个小时
尤其是初学者来讲
在检视自己的
当天的交易记录
所以要花这个时间才是有效的
对啊
他讲嘛
这是最有效的训练嘛
对
要去想为什么会做错
那该如何调整
不只这样而已
要有方法
我那时候在戴海归的时候
我都要求就是
一定要做两个小时
交易检讨
把今天每一笔
几乎都掉出来看
对
每一筆到底哪裡對哪裡錯
然後你要看整體去檢討今天每一天
我的勝率是多少
賠率是多少
然後我最常講的就是
最有效的檢討就是今天最大的那一段
你有沒有吃到
ok 那你吃到多少
然後再來就是你用多少的部位吃到
對
檢討這些其實真的就要兩個小時
那你因為每天要做檢討你不敢亂下
你只要亂下的話你檢討不出來
其實這個開玩笑
很多散户遇到第一個
他們也會檢討
如果說賠錢檢討沖銷
他們就檢討
營業員去計較
發現都被成本吃掉了
是他的問題
對呀
這個真的是贏家跟輸家的一個很大的差異
每一個人都是這樣
我自己也是
早期做了5年
差不多做了5年的交易檢討
那這個是真的是
最苦
但是最有效的訓練
對這個非常認同
但是沒有用
我知道你推廣不出去
你去推廣交易檢討沒有人會理你
最利益的用語是那少數人
少數人到最後就會成為你客戶裡面的贏家
這個真的很少人能夠做到長期而有效的監視
就是把對的東西持續講
對那真的你說他有沒有要懂
他可能有一天他自己會內化
對那我會建議你啦
就是把交易紀錄根據客戶不同的屬性去做
不同的格式
比方說你比較有年紀的或比較忙的
你不可能叫他每一筆都做
還要去統計什麼
其實我們幫客戶做這個交易紀錄
那倒是可以
那就看他听不听进去而已
那变成是你要很累
对啊像我们有时候
因为客户安排那种交易探讨
那我又想帮他做交易见解
我见解花很多时间
过来的客户你看他有没有听进去
他有没有做笔记跟那个眼神
后面就大概两三天就知道说
这个是有没有吸收的
那你们就最好是设计一些软体
能够比较快速的把他的
胜率啊
赔率那些
模组公式化
对然后着档啊
像我后来有设计一套软体
我那时候培育海龟的时候
设计一套软体
每天他们就输入就好了
每天就把自己的档案输进去
他就全部都跑出来
对
你今天的着价是多少
胜率多少
录胜多少
最大的一笔是多少
最大的亏损是多少
全部然后有没有违规
因为每个人可能他的愿意
投入交易检查的时间都不一样
所以这个你可能可以去规划一下
不如是可以有不同的格式
ok
根据他的那种成熟度
像我刚刚讲的
你到高界以后
我就只跟你检查今天最大那一段行情
你做了什么
因为你其他人都没有用
你讲这个也非常有感
对啊
今天输赢我才讲说一天你做当中的
你一天的输赢
其实就在那一段行情发动
那五分钟十分钟
就决定你今天的输赢
对那就像我们有一些
堪称那个level已经是赢家等级了
跟我们做交易探讨
其实也是在检讨说
欸为什么那一段我们没做
对对
你去讲一个大方向
或讲一个今天整个怎么样没有意义
其他的那个对他来讲就是
不是重点的
对甚至有可能就是他都在试单
所以那沒什麼好檢討的
是
那我們來看一下他是怎麼說的
他說啊
你要去檢討哪些交易賠錢賺錢
該大賺卻沒有賺到
該小賠卻變大賠
對
這個都是重點啊
那哪些是你不守機率去賺到錢
守機率卻賠到錢
這是另外一種對不對
這個下一本那個Face思考有講到
就是通常都會分兩種
守機率不守機率賺錢賠錢
就產生四個向線
對
就是守機率又賺到錢
守機率卻賠到錢
不守機率卻賠到錢
不守機率就賠到錢
這四個四雙
差不多啊
我覺得贏家講的東西就差不多
那大概到這樣子去也可以做一個蠻有效的交易檢討
我覺得今天盡量很高啊
謝謝謝謝
這本書還不錯啊
對那個像我這個就完全都提不到
聰明哥整理的重點
對很棒
這些都是我覺得能夠跟我產生高度共鳴的部分
對
那因為這本書
我一開始其實老實講我沒有抱很大的期待
因為總覺得說很年輕人
除了輸我們總會以老賣老一下
因為畢竟他跟我應該都有差一二十歲了嘛
是
大家都說他不錯
而且我確實去問過是真的他是有市場上真的贏家
是
所以我覺得說那難得願意分享
應該我們也要放下
我們要謙虛啊
要去看看人家現在年輕人到底程度在哪邊
我一看必須說這本書含金量比我想像中還要高很多
是
那我也從當中也有去強化一些我自己原來的觀念
那也有學到一些新的東西
所以我覺得呢
好像有那個必要跟大家分享
這本書給大家推薦
希望大家都去買
因為真的沒有很多錢
這種書買了重複看
一樣我覺得這本書
值得你去看個五遍十遍
尤其對小白來講
對得到幾個觀念就非常有價值
對一本書幾百塊
對看個五遍十遍
那也很感謝呢
這些年輕的成功超班人
願意出來跟大家分享
因为这个我们毕竟是最贴近的
是是
Local的市场
是
OK
好 那我们这本书呢
就跟大家分享到这边
这希望大家喜欢哦
好 谢谢Tony哥的分享
好 谢谢
谢谢各位
如果喜欢我的内容
记得帮我按赞
订阅
开启小铃铛
我们下支影片见
拜拜